nos preguntan cuáles de las siguientes
rectas son paralelas y bueno antes de
ver las tres rectas que tengo aquí
quiero recordar que significa que dos
rectas sean paralelas dos rectas son
paralelas si tienen a ver pongámoslo
aquí
las si tienen la misma pendiente misma
misma pendiente pero no sólo es
pendiente lo que necesitamos es que
también corten al eje de las 10 en
puntos distintos o dicho de otra manera
si las ponemos en su forma y es igual a
mx más ven que la vez sea distinta no
voy a poner así la ve
distinta d
distinta ok ahora que recordamos que
tienen que ser rectas con la misma
pendiente pero que pasen por un punto
distinto dicho otra manera que tengan
una vez distinta entonces vamos a
trabajar con estas tres y la primera es
la recta a la recta a de que me dice lo
voy a poner justo aquí la recta dice 2
que es igual a 12 x + 10 ok y si
nosotros queremos ver su pendiente y su
ordenada al origen que te parece si
despejamos allí y bueno de aquí despejar
que ya es muy sencillo porque lo único
que tenemos que hacer es dividir entre 2
esta parte entre 2 esta parte también
entre 2 y me va a quedar entonces antes
de poner si estos dos se van y me queda
que james es igual a 6 veces x + 5 + 5
10 entre 25 ok de aquí estoy diciendo y
lo voy a poner con este color que su
pendiente pendiente
pendiente es 6 ok es igual a 6 que es
justo el número que está al lado de la
equis y su ordenada al origen de la
intersección con el eje sly es va a ser
en el valor de 5 de lujo ahora fijémonos
en la recta vez vamos a hablar de la
recta b y para eso voy a utilizar este
color
ok recta ve que me dice la recta ve lo
que me dice es que quien es igual a 6 de
aquí ya tengo despejada james y me dice
que es igual a 6 pero ten cuidado eso no
quiere decir que mi recta tiene una
pendiente de 6 esto es exactamente lo
mismo que escribir que ya es igual a 0 x
x + 6 si te das cuenta aquí no tengo x
ésta es una recta constante y por lo
tanto lo podemos escribir de esta
siguiente manera y es igual a 0 x x 0 x
x 0 + 6 o dicho de otra manera ya
podemos concluir y déjame poner con este
color que su pendiente su pendiente es
el número que está al lado de la x en
este caso es
pero tiene una pendiente de 0
precisamente porque es una recta
constante y su ordenada al origen es
decir b es igual a 6 esta recta cruza al
eje de las 10 en el valor de 6 de lujo
entonces ya sabemos que la recta y la
recta en definitiva no son paralelas
porque ésta tiene una pendiente de 6 y
éste tiene una pendiente de 0 y deben de
tener la misma pendiente así que
trabajemos ahora con la recta c
vamos a trabajar ahora con la recta cm y
la recta c que me dice bueno que ye
menos 210 menos 2
es lo mismo que 6 por equis más 2 ok y
bueno esta recta está en su forma punto
pendiente lo que quiere decir y de hecho
de una forma muy rápida podemos concluir
déjame ponerlo con este color que su
pendiente pendiente es justo el número
que está multiplicando este paréntesis
su pendiente en este caso es 6 y bueno
no sabemos jornada al origen pero lo que
sí podemos saber es que ésta
pasa por el punto menos 222 recuerda que
a éste se le cambia el signo ya ésta se
le cambia el signo las rectas que se ven
de la forma punto pendiente y vamos a
recordarlo si su pendiente pendiente es
m ok y pasa por el punto a como b
entonces su ecuación sería de menos b es
igual a m por x menos a de lujo y bueno
de esta manera puedo encontrar su
pendiente muy fácil es este número de
aquí y puedo encontrar el punto por el
que pasa el punto b le cambiamos el
signo a éste le cambiamos el signo este
ahora si te das cuenta tiene la misma
pendiente que la recta puedo decir que
es casi seguro que sean paralelas o es
la misma recta y para eso necesitamos
saber cuánto vale su ordenada el origen
y bueno para saber cuánto vaya sorda el
origen que te parece si despejamos de
que ye yé menos 2 es igual a 6x más 12
multiplique este por este y este por
este y es igual a 6 x + 12 y éste pasa
sumando más 2 es decir estoy sumando 2
de ambos lados de esta ecuación james es
igual a 6 x + 14 y aquí está de lujo
porque ya puedo saber cuánto vale b b
vale 14 y es justo lo que necesitaba
tener la misma pendiente ajá y además
que tuviéramos una vez distinta
tengo una vez de 14 cortamos el eje de
leyes en esta recta en el valor de 14
pero tengo una pendiente de 6 mientras
que en esta recta tengo una pendiente de
6 y una vez de 5 por lo tanto puedo
concluir y lo voy a poner con este color
puedo concluir que la recta recta
es paralela es paralela a la recta hace
a la recta se dé el lujo hemos acabado
este problema